mama D and Ernest you guys have put your
relationship all out there yeah people
know it well why did you want to do this
show because things have happened on a
show that we're on and I felt like for
us to put our reality out there and you
not help us to help that we really need
so you looked over us so when we TV came
to us he said you know what if we can
get some help because we honestly love
each other that's what we so you know we
reached back out and we did this is the
last chance that me and Ernie have to
save our marriage
why was this the last chance because
sometimes when we say I do and it says
for better worse that you seek help some
people we do bail out when it gets worse
and we have to like take inventory of
who we are and say I did get in from the
world and say I love this man and if I
can't stick with him through the worst
what good is this marriage so let's give
it this one last try to see how we can
find each other back this is a do-over
marriage is the second time around yeah
why is this a marriage worth fighting
for I thought it was myself I thought it
was actually mediate I thought marriage
boot camp was the opportunity when you
had that boot camp Nobbs
June but thinking well just push-ups I
got masculinity got the show I got a
fool of my wife that I am that man but
oh no they had a little tricks up their
sleeves for us and let me tell you went
the end of the day you're gonna need
some paja boots and some roll of toilet
paper a whole roll cuz
it's gonna get deep blue I cannot wake
up over the whole marriage is over just
one point I won't tell you a thing but I
was getting electrocuted and I said I
don't want because I saw having heart
palpitations hit they literally dragged
me and you know so we are really gonna
see things we've never seen before
Wow we're going there but relationships
at us today we are together because
there are some social media posts over
the last few months that sent some fans
like who know what's going on but
together today work together we stand
divided it we will not fall I've been in
this relationship in this marriage for
like 20-some years and I'm a days now
I'm not all that helps and so oh you
noticed in your lane cuz I can get in a
vehicle a car or I can get on the broom
it's up to you it was right I fly you
know take a little bit of a serious term
we know scrappy was in a car accident a
few months ago how is he doing now
he's out of the wheelchair on crutches
and they're just getting to the point
where he can bear weight so we're just
taking it one day at a time as you well
know that the bail is due to have my
second grandson and guess what he's due
on my birthday and his name is Breland
yeah that's a pretty coming that so
Prince to come in and you're okay
sharing your birthday the Queen's a kid
okay sharing her Big Dance blood over
everything flesh and blood over
everything
[Music]